ce qui fait un bon film d'horreur, je pense qu'un
méchant très fort est
une silhouette emblématique,
puis vous voyez ce visage de crâne blanc,
vous pouvez rire une seconde,
mais dès que ghostface est là-bas avec un
couteau comme si vous aviez vraiment peur,
vous voyez des fantômes face  comme votre souffle
s'arrête parce que vous savez ce que
cela signifie c'est tellement génial parce que c'est si inquiétant
et effrayant parce que vous ne savez pas qui est en
dessous n'importe qui peut être ghostface
bonjour sydney
voudriez-vous jouer à un jeu ghostface
est un tueur qui consiste à jouer à des jeux
mais quand vient le temps de faire le travail
c'est vraiment brutal et vraiment violent
c'est tellement intimidant quand le couteau est
dans la main c'est tellement effrayant
mais tu mets cette musique avec ce visage
il est aussi effrayant que
jamais
toi